sursaut national contre le racisme dans
tout le pays des manifestants par
dizaines de milliers à l'assemblée les
députés pour une fois unanimes fonte
d'acier dans le marché commun les neuf
prendre des mesures autoritaires
exceptionnel
ces messieurs bonsoir d'une dizaine de
milliers de personnes ont pris part
d'après midi à paris de la nation à la
république à la manifestation organisée
par le bras le mouvement contre le
racisme et pour l'amitié entre les
peuples
les personnalités politiques des
syndicalistes de tous les horizons
participaient à cette véritable
mobilisation contre le racisme le
fascisme et d'antisémite sur place à la
république françois comme actuellement
est sûre la pluie le cortège s'écoule
très lentement à la proche de la
république là pour depuis près de trois
heures maintenant
la manifestation a démarré place de la
nation cent mille cent cinquante mille
personnes
il est impossible d'évaluer le nombre
des manifestants qui défilaient
aujourd'hui à l'appel du mrap le
mouvement contre le racisme de la nation
à la république
la tête du cortège est arrivée vers 18
heures sur cette place de la république
actuellement la foule de manifestants
ces tirs toujours le long du boulevard
voltaire et du boulevard du temple
l'aspect le plus étonnant de cette
manifestation est sans doute la réunion
et même la fusion dans la dignité et le
calme de toutes les forces politiques
syndicales et des mouvements juifs les
parlementaires de la majorité défi n'est
donc qu'à quelques mètres de ce
d'opposition noyé dans la foule les
personnalités politiques étaient entrés
d'anonymes des hommes et femmes des
personnes âgées des très jeunes des
employés de bureau des professeurs des
secrétaires qu'elle ait tous quitté leur
lieu de travail
deux heures plus tôt pour venir
manifester deux types de slogan bouger
en entendre actuellement ont donc été
crié tout au long du cortège alors assis
à deux pas chiche mais aussi des
critiques directes contre le chef de
l'état contre le premier ministre et
contre le ministre de l'intérieur
le gouvernement a été acté de faciliter
la démission de monsieur bonnet a été
réclamée tout au long du cortège
on retiendra également le calme de cette
manifestation aucun incident notoire
n'est encore signalé vise à part
quelques bousculades les services
d'ordre des syndicats et des
organisations comme le renouveau juif
ont très bien canaliser ces milliers de
français à travers toutes ces grandes
artères de la nation à la république ce
que l'on peut dire ce soir c'est que
cette manifestation constitue une
première car les français présents ici
sont venus simplement pour la liberté et
la démocratie personne est en tout cas
aucun parti politique ne peut
revendiquer pour lui seul les tentatives
de récupération qui offrait depuis
vendredi un climat tendu et même malsain
ces tentatives sont aujourd'hui balayé
par ce rassemblement car il était bien
étonnant de voir réunis dans un même
cortège
françois mitterrand bernard stasi
georges marchais bernard pons edmond
maire brice lalonde jean pierre pierre
bloch et même andré henry à noter
également la discrétion des forces de
police dans tous ses quartiers traversés
par les manifestants il faut dire que
les deux syndicats police qui
participaient au défilé et qui ont comme
vous le savez est énoncé la présence
d'éléments néo nazis dans les rangs de
la police ont été aujourd'hui très
applaudi veillons à ce moment les
personnalités en tête du cortège
présent dans cette manifestation
d'aujourd'hui
notre confrère jean françois kahn qui va
dans quelques secondes nous apporter son
témoignage
voyez que la manifestation auquel nous
assistons ce soir est un événement tout
à fait ordinaire et extraordinaire par
l'immensité de la foule qui était son
but au panama
non aux thérapies pour dire non au
racisme
il y a quelques années en 1961 lorsque
par exemple on rêve avec un attentat
défiguré une petite fille s'appelait
d'être inondés il ya les 60000 personnes
qui spontanément étaient descendus dans
la rue j'en avais trouvé ça déjà
je vais sauter mais cette fois misé
chaque mauvais souvenir pour une autre
raison c'est que les gens qui sont ici
ce soir qui défilent ensemble et
peut-être la première fois qu'il faut
coude à coude
je veux dès la première fois titré hier
encore certains d'entre eux polémique
est durement échanger des injures ou du
vin sud il y à des communistes et des
socialistes c'est déjà pas mal mais il
ya aussi peut-être bien que la gauche
soit majoritaire des gens qui votent
pour lui des flux à faire j'ai vu des
députés giscardien aux déshérités golly
il ya nul il ya ici ce soir des
sionistes et des antilles il ya des gens
qui sont des partisans fanatiques
peut-être même d'israël et d'autres qui
sont des partisans parce qu en est il
des baisses
il y à des religieux et des mystiques il
ya des athées et des francs maçons et
ces gens qui demain vont recommencer
leurs polémiques leurs débats vont de
nouveau se donner des coups
ces gens là ont trouvé normal
aujourd'hui d'être ensemble parce qu'ils
vont vu apparaître
permettez moi l'expression la gueule
horrible du racisme la tête du monde du
fascisme alors ils sont là et je crois
que c'est en soi un événement
extraordinaire des manifestations inclut
également 20 diverses villes de province
elles ont été nombreuses et suivi nous
devrons évidemment pas vous les donnez
tout voici celle de montpellier lyon et
strasbourg il ya longtemps qu'une telle
unanimité ne s'était manifesté en france
en effet partout dans toutes les grandes
villes des manifestations et des défilés
se sont formées le plus souvent à
l'appel d'une europe mais aussi parfois
entraînements la manifestation la plus
marquante a peut-être été celle de
montpellier ou dix mille personnes ont
défilé sans cris chance le blanc dans un
silence impressionnant le plus souvent à
montpellier comme à lyon comme à rouen
les cortèges étaient menés par des
leaders juifs des syndicalistes des élus
locaux
aucun incident à signaler à l'heure
qu'il est mais à marseille l'émotion
était grande au moment où l'on a
découvert devant un bar tenu par un juif
une bombe
heureusement désamorcée à temps et puis
en manifesteront encore demain dans
certaines villes c'est le cas à
strasbourg le pc la cgt appelle dans
rangs un nouveau défilé pour demain soir
aujourd'hui malgré le mauvais temps
qu'un sens par montjoire s'étaient
rassemblés spontanément sur la place
principale de la ville
l'émotion soulevée par l'attentât de la
rue copernic sera bien en décembre
encore demain des français dans la rue
notamment peslier la nuit dernière une
dizaine d'actions antisémites avaient
été commises contre le domicile ou le
lieu de travail de personnes de
confession israélite plaques
professionnelles soulier patxi braille
seront jetés dans les couloirs
inscriptions of the year et à marseille
devant un bar tenu par une israélite mon
mieux pour l'instant vu de l'évêché je
persiste on a découvert 150 g de
dynamique
muni d'un détonateur avec une mèche
lente lac naturel marques déposées les
quatre militants néo-nazis qui était
encore en garde à vue qui est déjà fait
dans le cadre de l'enquêté sur
l'attentât de la rue copernic ont été
remis en liberté en fin d'après midi
aucune charge n'ayant été relevé
contre eux il n'y a donc plus personne
en garde à vue dans les locaux de la
brigade criminelle
cependant d'autres de l'interpellation
du même genre pourraient être effectués
et c'est le jour ce les faisons une
voiture samedi
ce boulevard saint-germain à paris
n'avait finalement à rien à voir avec un
attrape à l'extrême droite mais je donne
tout et ben le mari de la femme très
grièvement blessées dans l'explosion
serait l'auteur de cet acte il vient
d'être inculpé de tentative d'homicide
volontaire et placé sous mandat de dépôt
à la prison de la santé
mais mme simone veil était aujourd'hui
l'invité de nos confrères de rtl et du
monde pour leur nouvelle émission danse
hôtel numéro un rtn le monde
une madame veil présidente de
l'assemblée européenne et ancien
ministre de la santé le gouvernement
français avait été déporté dans les
camps nazis pendant l'occupation
et on ne peut pas faire que la
communauté juive qui a vécu quelque
chose qui est un communiqué nous ce sont
en état de choc
même si en définitive bon je viens
d'entendre les informations donnent à
penser qu'il va y avoir des révélations
sur cette affaire tiens mais je crois
qu'on ne peut pas effacer l'histoire est
que depuis 35 ans d'une certaine façon
nous avons vécu l'histoire en pensant
que il y avait eu des événements très
graves qui se fait passer et conduit des
événements vont nous avions vécu un
cataclysme à feu mais que tout pouvait
repartir et que nous pouvions vivre
normalement
vous avez dit rapidement lorsqu'on s'est
vu pour préparer cette émission je sais
maintenant que les programmes existent
et peuvent exister c'est vrai que je
pense que à partir du moment où on a le
sentiment qu'une fraction la population
peut-être à caqueter touché parce que
physiquement et qu'on trompe et pas
seulement par des paroles ou parlée par
dix du graffiti ou par des lettres
horrible car il ya des années que je
reçois de l'être comment table et en
inde en montant spécifique d'une de
personnes de 10 personnes en france pour
un groupe d'élèves mais à partir du
moment où on pense que c'est ces actes
peuvent devenir des violences physiques
réels
aboutissant à la volonté de tuer eh bien
ça se rapproche effectivement des
sentiments qui devait expirer
même si mes regrets dans une autre
partie d'émission a regretté la relative
discrétion at il dit du gouvernement
après l'attentât de la rue copernic à
l'assemblée nationale le président
chaban delmas a prononcé une allocution
dénonçant le terrorisme et la piscine et
east puis les députés unanimes se sont
levés contre lui et la mémoire du côté
couloir c'était aujourd'hui l'animation
dé grande rentrée parlementaire
tout le monde était là et tout le monde
parlait de la fe de fasciste et de
raciste
côté tribunes autour de madame chaban
delmas
il y avait aujourd'hui le grand rabbin
kaplan et allan rothschild
l'antisémitisme comme toute forme de
racisme et d'une attaque monstrueuse à
la dignité humaine et il ne sera pas
davantage tolérer qu'il y avait bientôt
un demi siècle et ceux qui ont vaincu
les nazis sont déterminés à en combattre
les résurgences enfin le terrorisme sous
toutes ses formes sous tous ses aspects
doit être étouffé dans l'oeuf le
terrorisme qui vise à saper les bases de
l'ordre républicain et de la communauté
nationale
nous y veillons l'assemblée en juillet
seul un essai de 12
un silence éloquent mais qui n'empêchera
pas les différents présidents de groupes
d'intervenir par le biais des rappels au
règlement pour demander une suspension
de séance
en mon nom une suspension de séance qui
permet de débuter du respect des
participants s'est manifesté je vous
remercie et j'ai fait va pas qu'une
famille ne sait quel temps mais nous on
corrompt tout nouveau les taux demain il
s'agira d'un grand pas et vont pas se
prononcer l'interprétation toute
différente des communistes à la demande
de suspension tellement retrouve après
cet après midi nous allons d'aller
mais raymond barre ne viendra que demain
comme prévu pour s'expliquer devant une
assemblée pour une fois unanimes
suffrages exprimés 475 majorité absolue
de 138 pour 475 après quoi une séance a
été suspendue afin de permettre aux
députés d'aller participer à la
manifestation formations occupent aussi
bien au sénat le président pères a
assuré la communauté villepin ce de
toutes les solidarités de sonatel visant
devant le déchaînement de violence et la
montée de nouveaux périls
nous devons tous ensemble faire face
avec détermination et sans faiblesse
l'entreprise criminelle de
déstabilisation vise sans aucun doute
les institutions de notre éthique
pour en revenir à l'assemblée jean
pierre joxe parti socialiste a demandé
s'il était exact que le commissariat du
16ème à paris avait été informé il ya
plusieurs semaines de préparatifs dans
l'attentât contre la synagogue de la
victoire
monsieur gautier débuté tard et réclame
l'indemnisation des victimes
le dommage matériel de l'attentât je
chine au président du groupe udf à
l'assemblée propose de créer une
commission d enquête parlementaire pour
déterminer l'évolution du terrorisme
dans le monde et les mesures à prendre
face mara grand pays démocratique comme
la france au conseil de paris après une
minute de silence
je suis un maire de la capitale a dit la
mission la plus imminente des tarés tous
les cas c'est la défense de la société
de liberté respectueuse de toutes les
différences légitimes
le préfet de police monsieur sun veille
a lancé un appel à l'esprit civique de
la population parisienne pour inviter
ceux qui peuvent contribuer à l'enquêté
le faire et non pas une information de
dernière seconde
les enquêteurs pensent qu'il n'est pas
impossible que l'amour retrouvé
déchiqueté rue copernic a fait
l'attentât est été amenés par les
terroristes les policiers d'en
diversifier
il est propriétaire de l'engin n'a elle
pas quelles conclusions tirez-vous de
cette journée après la manifestation et
le siège au sein de l'europe et l'idée
principale qu'on peut retenir ce soir et
est tenu des contenus dans le terme même
d'unanimité et xavier vue c'est une
limite et à l'assemblée nationale même
s'il y eu des petites querelles de
procédure
mais les députés qui décident tous
ensemble de suspendre leurs travaux pour
descendre dans la rue
elle se met les manifestations du peuple
de paris c'est quand même un événement
politique est assez exceptionnel comme
est exceptionnel aussi cette
manifestation que nous avons pu si votre
salaire
un fait extraordinaire du jean françois
kahn et même si six ou sept unanimité il
ya encore bien des missions politiques
même si les hommes et les femmes qui
continuent encore à défiler à l'heure
qu'il est ne sont pas tous d'accord sur
tous les slogans et tout que les
banderoles qui peuvent être le long de
ce parcours
ils savent quand même ce qu'ils ont en
commun d'ailleurs à la chaîne ctv
et puis ce qui m'a frappé aussi nos
reporters le souligner sur cette dignité
c'est une discipline qui transparaissent
à travers les images qui sont parvenus
tout au cours de cet après midi qu'ils
sont parvenus tout à l'air encore est la
province l'été suivant mon histoire à
prédire la principale crainte c'est la
crainte de cette spirale de la violence
eh bien elle je crois qu'on peut dire ce
soir que si les organisateurs de toutes
ces manifestations à paris à travers la
france ont pris certains risques ils ont
su assumer ses risques et leur réponse
la réplique l'attentât de vendredi soir
mais bien c'est l'expression d'une force
une force immense et qui sait ce conflit
et demain eh bien demain le gouvernement
ce qui l'est suite de cet attentat la
synagogue de la rue copernic à l'ordre
du jour 2 les délibérations du conseil
des ministre de l'après midi le barda
devant l'assemblée nationale
et je vous signale d'ailleurs que
antenne 2 a décidé de retransmettre en
direct de ce débat à partir de 15h le
débat va donc se poursuivre non plus
seulement deux dans l'opinion publique
mais dans le cadre traditionnel dans le
cadre institutionnel c'est à dire le
parlement et je crois qu'il était que ce
débat est quelque chose de normal
quelque chose de nécessaire
j'ajouterai même quelque chose de sain
après finalement toutes les querelles
qui lui ces jours ci autour du thème de
la récupération politique
au fond dans cette affaire c'est la
démocratie qui s'est trouvée mise en
cause
il est parfaitement normal il est
nécessaire je le répète que ce soit les
élus de la nation que ce spacieux qui
sont l'émanation même de la démocratie
qui discutent démocratiquement pour la
défendre et pour étudier quelles sont
les causes du mal et quels en sont les
relais et je pense que demain au cours
de leurs débats les députés se
souviendront de la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui
ils se souviennent eux se souviendront
de cette foule immense qui est descendue
dans les rues de paris précisément pour
défendre la démocratie
la chirurgie rappel est en crise
l'europe produit plus d'acier qu'elle ne
peut en vendre ses plus gros clients
l'industrie automobile et le bâtiment
connaissent depuis des mois une baisse
de régime qui vise à organiser le marché
de l'acier plutôt que de laisser faire
jusqu'à provoquer l'effondrement total
des moins concurrentiels parmi les
entreprises sidérurgiques européenne les
neuf vont tenter de répartir la pénurie
à cet effet les ministres représentant
les neuf états membres sont réunis
aujourd'hui à luxembourg pour décider
s'il convient de mettre en oeuvre une
politique autoritaire de réduction de la
production à l'échelle européenne
mais c'est vrai c'est une question en
fait c'est de savoir comment on va
répartir les ennuis la pénurie et les
ennuis des six
sont très graves ni dédié les pratiques
ou aux clients de l'acier c'est à dire
notamment l'automobile le sud bâtiments
sont en pleine crise depuis des mois
maximum depuis beaucoup plus longtemps
et l'europe c'est vrai produit en ce
moment beaucoup plus baissé de l'ordre
de 15% que ce quelques consommée est
même que c'est elle peut vendre alors
tous ces magnifiques j'utilise de
production réorganiser à grand-peine
sont sur le point et qu'elle plus de
perdre de l'argent
les sidérurgistes d'aynac enfermés dans
les conflits de la concurrence n'ont pas
su s'entendre à l'amiable pour
harmoniser leurs productions la
commission européenne se propose de les
y contraindre par joie autoritaires
comme le permet le traité de rome prend
pareil cartes que l'on appelle état de
crise
manif est l'objet même de la réunion
luxembourg aujourd'hui est de donner à
l'autorité européenne laval
indispensable de chacun des neuf
gouvernements concept très ci fait
chaque entreprise sidérurgique de la
communauté se liera soucier des quotas
de production qui ne devra pas dépasser
sous peine damine la baisse de
production d'ensemble devrait atteindre
de 15 20 % selon les produits c'est
considérable et l'on peut craindre des
répercussions sur l'emploi
c'est pourquoi la commission européenne
étudie actuellement un plan de t&d 600
millions de crédits pour atténuer le
coût social de l'opération
et tout ça se discute en ce moment même
à luxembourg où la réunion des 9
ministres européens se poursuit en ce
moment on en connaîtra les résultats car
ce soir ou demain matin mais il est trop
bas pour la chair et qu'on se dirige
donc vers une réduction autoritaire
la production d'acier européenne
autrement dit un autre terme l'europe
s'efforce de gérer la crise en la
répartissant le premier ministre a reçu
les principaux dirigeants du crédit
agricole à l'ordre du jour la
répartition des excédents ou si vous
préférez les bénéfices du crédit
agricole
une décision définitive sera prise à ce
propos le 24 octobre
en fait au-delà de cette décision c'est
à venir du crédit agricole qui je
discutais ce matin depuis quelques temps
certaines voix s'élèvent plaidant en
faveur d'une privatisation de la banque
pertes
voyons ce que représente aujourd'hui cet
établissement bancaire qui a grandi si
vite depuis une quinzaine d'années jean
luc muzet
créé en 1920 la caisse nationale de
crédit agricole est un établissement
public de l'état avec 94 caisse
régionale 3000 caisse locale et plus de
dix mille bureaux
le crédit agricole est la plus grande
banque de france mais se félicite même
d'être la première banque mondiale
plus de 10 millions de personnes ont un
compte au crédit agricole en 1979
la banque verte a prêté 14 milliards de
francs à l'agriculture et le double soit
28 milliards de francs pour financer le
logement ce qui a permis à 300000
personnes d'acquérir ou d'améliorer leur
habitat 80% de ces prêts et en
distribuant milieu rural
côté ressources plus de deux millions
cinq cent mille comptes et plans
d'épargne-logement ont été ouverts au
crédit agricole
toujours en 79 soit un tiers du marché
français
mais le crédit agricole c'est aussi une
vaste entreprise qui emploie plus de 65
mille salariés 50000 administrateurs
élus et bénévoles des agriculteurs pour
la plupart participent activement à la
gestion de la main très bientôt une
réforme des statuts du crédit agricole
va être engagée statut qui date de 1920
la procédure risque d'être long elle
sera parlementaire en effet tout
changement dans l'organisation du crédit
agricole doit se traduire par une
modification du code rural et des lois
de 1920 qui régissent le crédit agricole
mutuel et les employés luc rivière du
cloud et est en grève aujourd'hui pour
manifester leur inquiétude quant à la
règle le salon automobile continue à
attirer dans le monde au rond-point de
défense cela prouve que l'automobile
intéresse toujours beaucoup de français
mais leur comportement change primo il
ya plus longtemps leur voiture
deuxièmement ils ont de plus en plus
portés vers des petites cylindrées ce
qui est normal et troisièmement ils
achètent plus volontiers que jadis des
voitures d'occasion
à l'arrivée ce qui a enquêté sur ce
marché de la voiture d'occasion
pourquoi acheter une voiture d'occasion
c'est une route à l'occasion enfin
j'espère que river la messe avec elle
tout en convenir à parce que je n'ai
plus les moyens d'acheter une voiture
mal
neuf plaintes nan j'ai dit pourquoi pas
ce que ça révèle une vitesse copie
trouvant que j'en avais que cherchez
vous les moyens pour la promenade du
dimanche puis pour aller au travail et
éventuellement alors s'il n'est pas
question
non c'est assez cher et c'est pas les
moyens 4 million de voitures d'occasion
sont immatriculés chaque année en france
soit deux fois plus que de wayne rooney
ou ea qui a fait une voiture d'occasion
la moitié du marché se réalise de
particulier à particulier presse
qu'aucune annonce ou bien par relation
l'autre moitié revient aux
professionnels une très petite part pour
les garagistes et les marchands qui font
que de l'occasion la plus grande part a
été conquise par les succursales et
filiales des constructeurs en effet
l'acheteur éventuel d'un véhicule neuf
se décident plus volontiers sachant la
défense de bien vous vendre sa voiture
malgré cela en huit mois les ventes de
véhicules neufs ont baissé de 5,7 pour
cent
le marché de l'occasion ne prendrai
c'est lui que de 2%
il ya donc globalement perte de
clientèle cela n'inquiète pas trop le
responsable d'un organisme de vente de
particulier à particulier
c'est une tendance qui remonte à fin
juin qui ne s'est pas démenti depuis fin
juillet soit la raison essentielle qui
est en fait qu les voitures neuves de
plus en plus chère est à l'heure
actuelle croit silva tionale il faut
d'abord vendre la voiture et l'autre
sept d'occasions tout le monde a du mal
à acheter une voiture neuve elle a du
mal après une opa sur potash
on aurait pu penser que le
ralentissement
la vente des voitures neuves et
faciliter la vente de bateaux d'occasion
n'en est rien à l'heure actuelle
l'évolution et parlait cet optimisme
prudent de réserver l'affiché chez les
vendeurs particuliers se retrouvent chez
les professionnels la diminution des
ventes de neuf c'est à dire la
diminution des futures voitures
d'occasion mais inquiète la puce l'écart
n'est pas n'est pas encore suffisant
pour qu'il y ait une influence il est
exact il faut qu'il y est un juste
équilibre
mais l'écart entre les ventes de neuf et
d'occasion n'est pas encore suffisante
pour que ça une affluence grave
les conducteurs concerne-t-il leur vécu
plus longtemps qu'autrefois
c'est indiscutable pourquoi limitations
de vitesse donc eu lieu au moindre
pouvoir d'achat également qu'il diminue
ce qui fait prolongé donc et ce sera la
deuxième tendance du marché de
l'occasion son pays ce nom la première a
pour l'heure est à sa stabilité
le stock actuel des véhicules d'occasion
et équivalents en nombre à celui de
l'année dernière par contre sa valeur a
augmenté le prix moyen de reprise d'une
automobile et de 14 mille francs contre
12 millions il ya un an dernières
confrontations les moyennes cylindrées
15 cents à 2 litre se vend moins bien
d'occasion la clientèle préfère la
petite case celle qui boit peu et dans
la vignette n'est pas trop cher à
l'autre extrémité de la gamme les
grosses cylindrées trouve encore des
admirateurs assez fortunés pour leur
faire la cour et les épouses et
construira quirin l'armée irakienne se
prépare à lancer une nouvelle offensive
généralisée dans la région pétrolière du
khouzistan à meyrin un conte doit
ininterrompue de véhicules blindés
d'acheminer sdv sur le fond et leur part
l'armée irakienne pilonnent à
l'artillerie lourde
la ville pétrolière barrage toujours
contrôlé par l'iran et n'est pas majeur
les iraniens affirment que la région de
khoramshahr est sous le contrôle complet
de l'armée iranienne appuyez vous voyez
par les gardiens de la révolution
islamique et bill de dépêches par la
population locale
quant à la jordanie elle est
pratiquement entrée en guerre aux côtés
de l'irak en fournissant aux troupes de
bagdad un soutien logistique
cet engagement inquiète sérieusement les
etats-unis qui ont demandé aura une
chaîne de jordanie de ne plus
irak afin de ne pas provoquer les
représailles de l'iran contre le détroit
d'ormuz qui commande vous le savez la
route du pétrole
monsieur concept casals trader d'état
espagnol chargé des relations avec la
communauté européenne a eu de nombreux
entretiens aujourd'hui à paris il a
déclaré que l'atmosphère entre la france
et l'espagne s'améliorer nettement et il
s'est dit très heureux de la terre reçu
à paris la date de l'adhésion de
l'espagne communauté libye n'est pas
essentiel l'objectif prioritaire de
madrid de continuer à préparer cette
adhésion
après demain jeudi à 20h30 vous pourrez
voir sur notre chaîne jaurès il est mort
d'un ce service c'est un très beau film
réalisé pour un thème de par ange casta
l'existence exemplaire besoin jaurès y
est évoquée avec une grande rigueur
historique
c'est le comédien bernard fresson qui a
pris les traits de ce grand défenseur de
la paix que jaurès
la ressemblance on veut dire livre
indications être à part
vous allez vous en rendre compte dans le
court extrait que voici un avant comme
rejeté la version
la diplomatie sont rompues entre autres
les chats serbie
vous en voyez cette dépêche d'urgence
s'est adressé à camille huysmans
secrétaire du bureau de l'internationale
socialiste bruxelles il faut que je
fasse un papier pour l'humanité de
demain matin
quand l'autre est annexé la bosnie
herzégovine
nous n'avions le droit de lui opposer
aucune remontrance puisque nous nous
étions engagés au maroc et que nous
avions besoin de nous faire pardonner
nos péchés en pardonnant les péchés des
autres alors notre ministre des affaires
étrangères disait à l'autriche
nous vous passons la postière ses
copines à condition que vous passiez le
maroc et nous disions à l'italie tu peux
aller en tripolitaine puisque moi je
suis au maroc
tu peux aller à l'autre bout de la rue
puisque moi j'ai volé à cette extrémité
si chaque peuple apparaît à travers les
rues de l'europe avec sa petite tache et
maintenant voilà lé incendie
la météo demain le temps sera frais et
instable en toutes régions sauvé nuages
et averses alterneront des chutes de
neige ont lieu en moyenne et haute
montagne mais vent d'ouest nord ouest
seront assez fort au nord de la loire
ainsi que près du col de l'oeillon nous
retournons avant de rendre l'antenne
avec transforme et passe de la
république
quelles sont les dernières informations
données et bien les dénégations
continuent d'arriver place de la
république dans la nuit et sous la pluie
mais toujours dans le calme et l'ordre
le cortège se disloque
au fur et à mesure du champ car il est
passé chez en avez vous avez suivi nos
rues et ses délégations
oui bien écouté depuis plus de trois
heures le cortège défile maintenant
après le parti communiste le parti
socialiste vient d'arriver place de la
république avec ce slogan union action
contre le fascisme
on a vu côte-à-côte messieurs mauroy
rocard et jospin en tas n'ait entamé
l'international avec la foule
on peut penser maintenant que la
manifestation durera encore au moins une
heure sinon deux puisque plusieurs
milliers de personnes de manifestants
sont encore bloqués rue du faubourg
saint-antoine et boulevard du temple
voilà léon zitrone nous vous rendons
l'antenne sur ces images de l'arrivée du
cortège place de la république toujours
dans le calme et l'ordre et tout allait
très mal en présentant les informations
dernier est niché à 23h30 vous donnera
d'autres détails sur la manière dont la
manifestation a continué à se dérouler
et demain aussi bien avec un pic 2010
coloma de 20 heures
vous retrouverez les études envoyés
spéciaux d'antenne 2 aux états unis qui
vous présenteront la ville-etat houston
au texas
la soirée
à